Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
Okay.
What's going on guys? This is Rob and we're continuing DCC. Uh,
and in this one we are picking up with part five or whatever part this happens
to be, but the, the DC's dead planet event. Right? So in this video,
we pick up with John Constantine and Dr. Fate while they're heading into a
really just Constantine heading into one of the doors of the tower of faint.
And the funny thing about this is that he actually won't let Dr. Fait end,
right? Because it's kind of like this door is closed. Uh,
it's a private meeting home slice. You got to stay out here.
And so once he actually gets inside, you know, because there's,
there's not really a doorknob readily available for Dr. Fait to use Constantine
kind of spawns. One goes inside and then shuts it.
And of course the doorknob vanishes,
but we ended up finding out inside this room is estrogen and estrogen.
Of course, always speaking in rhymes,
kind of follows up with the previous discussion they had about trigon coming to
earth. And that when, when Constantine kind of asked for an update here, right?
Like what's the update, like how long until trigon gets here.
And the responsible estrogen is you have three days,
you have three days until trigon makes his move and he comes to earth.
And so it was kind of like, okay, now the other part of this is that the green,
ah, this is being used by, you know, the,
the ultra wealthy and powerful in order to spawn, you know,
vegetables and things like that is still kind of off swamp thing. Right?
So that needs to be dealt with, but the immediate threat,
as far as Constantine is concerned, is to focus on essentially taking out the,
uh, taking out, try again, or at least trying to find some way to defeat,
try again, which is a tall order,
even for the most powerful of beings inside of DC comics,
let alone just John Constantine. Right? And so he takes a cloak of rag man,
which as we know,
had the ability to absorb the souls of other people and then leaves from there.
He basically assembles what is for the most part, a strike team.
And this strike team of course, is more or less being led by Batman,
by Damian Wayne, uh, alongside, uh, Rose the daughter of Deathstroke.
In addition to Jason Todd, and a few others. Now,
the funny thing about this is that Rose and Jason Todd had actually gotten
married. I don't like that. This just kind of happened off panel.
I think it would have been cool to actually see how Rose and Jason Todd really
began to hit it off,
how that romance really began the blossom and how the two of them ended up
getting married.
It really kind of seemed to be Rose's clairvoyance that led to like, okay,
we're going to get married because I saw it happening. So let's just do it now.
And then they did. So I don't really know,
but the important thing here is that what they ended up doing is transitioning,
you know, to Nanda Parbat to basically, you know, well,
really concentrating using the green to get there.
And then of course the rest of them using a portal to access it.
But with Nanda par bot, you know, essentially the league of assassins,
more or less being infected here, uh,
what you also have is just this colossal army. And th th the issue that,
that you really have really kind of comes from Damian Wayne,
which is really designed to sort of show how far he's come and the time that he
took on the mantle of Batman versus when we first saw him in the sense that he
maintains the ideology of Bruce Wayne, that if there's a cure here,
that we cannot kill these people,
like if there is a definitive cure and that you're a resides in the realm of the
new gods or whatever it is, they have to do to get it.
They can't kill everybody here because technically they be killing people who
could be safe. And so it's, it's a bit murky here because in my mind,
I would be like, no, I mean, you could save them, but if you guys die,
the world's going to be destroyed by trigon. And so it's like, Hey, look,
I'm sorry, all you innocent people, but our need is greater than yours.
So we got to die, right? I mean, we won't intentionally kill you,
but if you want up honest and you get in our way,
then we're going to do you in that's, that's what I would do.
But I'm also a little more hardcore, right? I mean, I'm,
I'm a little more in the,
I am in the philosophical views that the ends do justify the means,
depending on what the ends are. Right. And so, because of that,
you ended up seeing Rose, who basically, again,
uses her kind of clairvoyance to sort of where she needs to go in order to,
to get to where they need to be.
And then basically knocks on the door and you end up being met by Boston brand
by dead man. Right? He has,
of course the ability to possess the bodies of others.
And so as he opens the door, the forces of Nanga Parbat come pouring out.
And then of course start attacking all these, these undead people who are here,
right. Basically kind of, you know,
taking care of them while Constantine heads inside Nanda Parbat meets with Rama
Krishna and, and basically accesses the spear of destiny.
Now [inaudible] is a being out there, um,
who represents karma more or less. So she is in fact, a literal goddess.
So killing her isn't necessarily something that can be done easily.
The most powerful of beings out there can, but not everybody can, right. I mean,
she gets, for the most part in immortal person, she could live on forever,
but the spear of destiny is actually designed to kill a God. Right now.
It doesn't mean he could stab her once and then she's dead.
But the problem with this is that she won't let him take it.
This is very much like a Holy figure. This is the Holy thing,
the spear of destiny. You can't just take it and walk away with it.
It doesn't work that way. And so,
because of the fact that John Constantine knows this,
he does the only thing that he can do. He stabs Rama Krishna,
and then takes a spear of destiny for himself. Now,
like immediately after that dead man shows up, like my God, what did you do?
Goes to attack Constantine and Constantine absorbs dead man into the rag man
cloak. So now Boston brand has gone, right? He's dead.
He's effectively gone here. I mean, I guess not dead in the traditional sense,
but by all standards of measurement is dead. Now, as far as Rama Krishna goes,
she'll survive, right? I mean, she can't really be killed by that,
but everybody's kind of to Constantine, but his whole, his whole stance here is,
look, guys, Trigon's coming to earth and he's going to kill us.
We don't really have time to play this game of what is the main thing to do.
Constantine is just such a mean thing to do. We don't have time for that, right?
Like this is the time to put up or shut up.
And your morals are going to be questioned here. If you can't handle that leaf,
right? Like this is not the time for why naivety and the idea of, well,
we can save everybody's life is a time to do what you got to do.
So if you can't man up,
then go play with the kitties while the rest of us do what needs to be done.
Right. It's, it's a, it's a time for men is a time for adults.
It's a time for grown women to do what needs to be done in this situation.
So following that, the end of transitioning to the rock of eternity,
which is amazing, right? They get through here. Of course,
you got the seven deadly sins, you know, all that kind of stuff.
But as soon as they get in,
and as soon as they get to where they're supposed to be,
they're immediately met by, by Freddie Freeman, right by captain Marvel, Jr.
Who literally goes on a rampage and just starts attacking all of them.
Now in that process,
you've also got the old wizard Shizam who seems to be infected,
or the very least is just kind of living this, this terrible, horrible faith.
And so what you end up having is Rose,
who kills the old wizard shazamm by stabbing him to the head with a sword,
when that happens and end up having like the staff of the old man,
which is what they were there for that, uh,
that Cassandra Cain is the one who picks it up at Cassandra Kane becomes the new
Shizam.
Now the funny thing about this is that with Freddie Freeman freaking out the way
he is, her power is equal to hit.
But one of the things that we're immediately told here is that Freddy Freeman
was just an orphan kid who got the power of shazamm. He's not a fighter.
Cassandra Kane has been fighting her entire life.
And she was trained by the single greatest fighter in the entirety of DC comics.
This is literally a girl born to kill, you know,
who she was born and bred to kill anybody in her path.
Her with the power of Shizam fighting off against Freddy Freeman.
It wasn't even a contest.
Pretty Freeman was dead before he even knew what happened.
The problem with this is that when Freddie Freeman initially launched his
attack, he immediately went for Jason Todd and crashed him into a wall.
And when that happened, he killed Jason Todd, right? So Jason, Todd is now dead,
which totally sucks. And so once they all basically ended up getting back there,
of course they bring Jason Todd's body, Batman freaks out, and he's like, dude,
you know, this, this is ridiculous, right? Like you got, you got, you got Jason,
Todd killed here. But at the end of the day, it was a small price to pay,
to save the earth, right? I mean, that's kind of the nature of the beast.
If these people out here really can be saved, then Jason, Todd, Jason, Todd,
his death,
while tragic pales in comparison to the billions of lives out there that could
be spared. It's simple utilitarianism,
the needs of the many outweigh the needs of the few.
And so what you end up getting is this kind of disembodied voice that tells John
Constantine, you deserve that, right? You deserve to get punched in the face,
the way that you did by Batman because of what you've done.
And we end up finding out this voice is coming from Jim Corrigan.
This voice is coming directly from the specter.
And when you have Constantine talking to him,
the specter is good ghost of wrath, things that, you know,
things I deserve the punch in the face, huge deal.
And he basically tells him like,
you're holding an object that could end even me. Right. That's concerning.
And I can stop you from what you're doing.
Constantine and Constantine's responses. You could write your,
the spirit of engines. You could kill me and everybody here, but ask yourself,
you ask yourself this question.
If I would go to these lengths to attain weapons that could kill gods.
Don't you think there's a reason why?
And Corgan kind of looks at him for a second and says, yeah, you're right.
And then leaves. That's kind of the funny thing here.
And this is something that I, I actually like about what's going on with,
with DC stead planet chemically, Jim Corgan could just purify the earth, right.
And just be done with it. He could purify all these people.
He could kill them all and their souls would pass onto Trigon's Rome and try and
wouldn't really have any reason to invade earth anymore.
It could all just be ended by vector, but it's cool that he's not,
it's cool that,
that this is not being invoked by up by DC because it would be lazy and it would
be an easy way out. It would be super lazy if he's just like,
if it's like wipes, his hands wages and he's dead done day saved. Thanks,
Jim Corgan. Let's meet up for beers and hot dogs, you know?
And that's that's it, but it would just be kind of land, right? It would,
it would be, it would be pretty lame, but I love what DC's doing here. Now,
if I'm a betting, man,
I think Jim Corgan is going to have a much bigger role to play and the events of
DCC. But for now, it's cool to see that he's not being used as an easy way out.
Well, that being said, guys, we're going to be this video to an end.
If you are new here,
it was explained to make sure you guys are the sub button to become part of the
Rob court. If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop them right now.
We'll catch you all later. Pers.
[Inaudible]
[inaudible].